Sometimes I sleep with a sound machine or
a fan.
It started in college to drown out loud roommates,
but now that I've read this research, I'll
probably quit!
'Sup sleepers, Trace here for DNews.
Sound machines are very popular with adults,
especially in noisy urban environments, because
they can use white noise to drown out other
sounds.
A new study in Pediatrics found, some infant
sound machines can hit 50 decibels!!
A JACKHAMMER is 95! 50 decibels is loud, and
since most adults keep them near the bed they
often do the same for their baby's infant
models.
Some of them even hang on the crib.
Sound machines for babies are meant to drown
out extraneous noise and let both babies and
adults sleep uninterrupted.
They create white noise, which is all the
frequencies of sound the human ear can hear,
combined together.
It's the white light or black paint of sound.
Some experts think it mimics what babies hear
in the womb; others look at how the brain
processes something like noise, versus tones
or notes.
The problem is babies experience sound MUCH
more intensely than adults because their straighter,
wider ear canal naturally amplifies sound.
Plus, like in The Matrix, they've never used
them before.
So long term exposure to 50 decibels could
potentially be bad for a baby's hearing.
Hearing is the ear and brain working together
to measure the waves of air pressure surrounding
your body.
The waves are perceived as sound, and measured
in decibels.
The human ear is very sensitive, registering
sounds as loud as jet engines and as slight
as a pin drop or hair brushing skin.
As our ears get used to the experience of
sound, loudness can become less intense -- we
get used to it.
For instance, sound machines and fans make
constant noise all night, and yet after a
while you feel like you're in a quiet room.
The reason we can sleep with something so
loud firing across our eardrums, has to do
with our brains.
When you're in a loud crowded place, you can
hear one or two conversations at once because
your brain is great at using visual information
combined with sound to pick out voices.
But, if you stand on the edge of a crowded
auditorium, it turns into a big mess -- even
TRYING to pick out a voice can be tough.
White noise is the same, with all those frequencies
going at the same time, your brain can't pick
out other sounds and just flat-out ignores
the whole batch.
This doesn't translate to every situation
though, the National Institute for Occupational
Safety and Health says ambient noise can increase
stress levels, exacerbate high blood pressure
and cause stress related problems like ulcers
and headaches.
And a study done with rats and published in
Physiology & Behavior found white noise can
affect the release of the stress hormone cortisol
-- rats exposed to white noise had 1.8 times
more cortisol!
In humans that affects planning, reasoning,
impulse control, and might even mess with
short term memory writing.
Another study from the University of California
San Francisco found white noise might keep
the brain from learning during sleep in children
-- delaying language acquisition and messing
with hearing.
If you HAVE to use a sound machine to sleep,
put it far from somewhere a baby sleeps, and
from YOU for that matter.
Keep the volume low, and set the timer so
it doesn't drone all night.
Less exposure to the constant drone might
be better for your brain and your kids.
What's your sound machine?
Fans?
Radiators?
The furnace or air conditioner turning on?
Dishwasher?
Or do you have an app on your phone?
Let's talk about it down below and see if
there's a better way than constant noise.
Be sure you subscribe for more DNews seven
days a week, and toss us a like before you
share with your friends.
Thanks for watching!